خليني اسال اليوم وين الاغنيه السودانيه
الاغنيه السودانيه موجوده بخير بخير جدا
ترى تصريح كبير هذا لا بخير جدا أنا بيجيل
الشباب ولا هو الجيل ما بين البينين ما
بين القديم
والتجديدة موجوده وبخير ان شاء الله يكون
بخير القديم والجديد وكله رغم التجديد
هو التجديد
الحياه في الاخره الحياه كلها تجيد
السودانيه ان
ها يعني الى العالم العربي
غيرها من الاغاني من جنسيات او دول اخرى
والله انا
لحد كبير قدره انه
تتخط الحدود وتنسمع في اغلب الدول العربيه
رغم اختلاف السلم انا خليني بس بعد ما
نسمع الاغنيه الاولى اللي راح نستفتح فيها
انا مجهز لك شيء لانه رغم الخلاف اللي دار
اهل الطرب ام درمان ولا بحري راح نرجع
مدني
من تحت الهواء
خلينا نسمع ونرجع شو رايك يلا
شو رح نسمعه
حنسمع يا بلد اصبحت كيف كلمات الدكتور
الشاعره الانسان عمر محمود خالد
الحاني انا
يلا ان شاء الله اصبح بخير يا رب يا رب يا
رب قريبه يا رب
[موسيقى]
يا بلد اصبحت اكيد
يا بلد اصبح
تك انت كيف عيونك من وجع سهر الليالي
الحاير في الصيف والخ
ريف اصبحت كيف
اصبحتك
[موسيقى]
وتسلم انت من المصاعب
والمتاعب والجر
اح
[موسيقى]
تك
كيف اصبح النيل والنخيل والبركات
كيف اصبح النيل والنخيل
والبراحات والتلاوه
والسمر
[موسيقى]
هناك
دمهورك
[موسيقى]
حصين اصبحت
وانا في حماك متوسما لمسه وفوق ساعه صفى
بلسم
[موسيقى]
جراحك اصبحت كيف انا مستلهمه
صباح في حضنك الزاني
[موسيقى]
والمصاعد
والمتاعب
وجراحات
والنزيف
اصبح كيف بعدما يعني تغير
من ام درمان الى بحر صوت الغناء بصوت
العزيز والرصاص هل سيعود الغناء الى انه
يكون هو العنوان العريض في السودان ان شاء
الله سعيد الغناء وسعود السودان نفسه
دوركم كفنانين
نتمنى ان شاء الله ان شاء الله سيعود
السودان كما كانوا سعود الغناء كما كان
بابناؤه
بمواطنين
بسواعده ان شاء الله ان شاء الله نتمنى
ذلك
الخلطه السحريه ما بين تاثير غربي مع
خصوصيه سودانيه بالالحان مع العود الجميل
خلينا ننهي صباح العربيه
بمعزوفه وبصوتك العذب
المجد والخلود لكل الشهداء السودان ولكل
سوداني نزفت دماغه في في ارضنا الابيض
هنغني لسفيان
كلنا ان شاء الله يرجع
[موسيقى]
لكم
في الحب حياه
وانا بيت
[موسيقى]
شفتك كتير نور في الخفوف
بفزعه الناس
يتقال لامه البي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وت
في الخفوق لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات